Settings activity is tied
to a list of preferences.
And the location edit text preference is
a custom preference that we have added
a widget to.
That widget, when clicked,
should build an intent and
start the place picker activity.
And when that activity returns,
it should have a place for
us, which means that we need to process
the result of the place picker called in
on activity result inside
of settings activity.
And if we have a new place we need
to store that in our location
shared preference.
Of course, before we can do this we have
to configure our app for the places API.
We need to add another
dependency to our build.gradle.
Recall how Google Play Services allows
you to specify the bundles that you care
about and ignore the others.
We already have the GCM bundle but
now we need to add the location one.
Then, to use the place picker, we need
to add a permission to our Android
manifest that will give us access to
location at a fine-grained detail.
Now let's look at our
place picker backwards.
What will we do once we have
the place picker response?
In on Activity Result and
Settings Activity, we need to parse and
store the address as our
new location for Sunshine.
First, we should verify that this
activity result is actually intended
for us.
And if it isn't, the place picker
response will pass it along to super
in order for them to handle.
If it is from the place picker and
a location was chosen,
then we can fetch the place
object from the place picker API.
Then look at the address to use as
a human readable location string and
store this in our shared preference for
location.
However, if the result
code is not successful,
we're going to gracefully fail
by not doing anything at all.
The most likely cause for
this is the user hitting back without
choosing a place at which point,
returning to an unchange setting
screen is the correct thing to do.
To launch the place picker
we need to build an intent.
But we are in a view not an activity,
which means we won't be able to
call start activity for a result.
So, we need to cast the context
to a specified activity.
In this case,
that would be settings activity.
This will allow us to make the call to
start the place picker, and by choosing
settings activity, the result of the
place picker ends up in the right place.
I'm going to let you figure out how to
build the intent and launch it however.